j'ai porté plainte contre le président
de la république
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et j'étais sidéré d'entendre ce qui
était rapporté sur le propos qu'il avait
tenus concernant les gens qui n'étaient
pas vaccinés je me disais mais didier
c'est pas possible tu peux pas tu peux
pas laisser passer quelque chose comme
ça et je suis la décision d'aller à la
gendarmerie je me suis dit finalement
tout citoyen en france peut s'exprimer
autrement que par les manifestations que
par les pétitions on peut par un peu de
choses pour qu'ils n'ont pas beaucoup
d'effets mes parents pendant sa propre
voix on peut pas déjà pour moi ça m'a
fait beaucoup de bien
[Musique]
je me suis la seule sentis insultés et
aussi dans ma citoyenneté puisque
dont tu considères que les gens qui ne
sont pas laxistes et irresponsables et
ne méritait pas la citoyenneté et là je
veux dire ça a été vraiment la cerise
sur le gâteau je comprends pas comme
président de la république puisse se
dire des choses comme ça c'est à dire
attiser la haine des gens les uns contre
les autres stigmatiser une partie de la
compilation dont il est responsable
[Musique]
ça c'est vraiment celle arme absolue
contre la population tchité la peur et
on voit que finalement ça fonctionne
plus c'est à dire
moi je suis prêt à assumer mais mon
choix est vraiment le sens de la place
au delà de la vaccination un président
ne peut pas faire ça mais c'était
vraiment le tournis des pôles maintenant